where are you going this outfit with
this hair hello bye bye I am so at the
mall between 1970 and 2017 the number of
American malls quadrupled population
didn't even double in the same timeframe
so yeah malls were opening really really
fast that growth slowed down about a
quarter of those malls that are left and
closed in the next five years some
people call this the death of the mall
and that's kind of true here's why that
matters our lives are lived in one of
three places the first is the home
second is your place of work and the
third place well that's any social space
outside of those first two there are
eight qualities that make for great
third places it sounds kind of academic
but trust me you know it when you see
them the best third places invite
conversation they're close to home and
lots of time can be spent without
spending a lot of money these are places
where people can exchange ideas have a
good time and build relationships in the
1950s America had a problem their
brand-new suburbs
lacked quality third places this guy
wanted to solve that problem so he
designed the first enclosed shopping
mall
the format caught on like wildfire
fueled by tax incentives to build new
developments that included malls soon
shopping centers were built by the Dozen
over the next 50 years there were over
1,000 enclosed shopping malls scattered
across the states they became the
hangout for America's youth the thing
about that is even Victor grew and
admitted his design was a monumental
failure because when you look at the
qualities of great third places malls
deliver on some but not all they're safe
and well-lit no one has to play host at
the mall and they're accessible no
matter the weather but on the flip side
you can't really walk to the mall you
need a car and once you're there
conversation should be the main activity
in a mall that's shopping the third
places should make everyone feel equal
the mall is more fun for the rich now
contrast that with a different take on
the third place the National Mall in
Washington DC it's open for long hours
the mood is playful it's free you can
visit with a short walk or by public
transportation with indoor and outdoor
public spaces and that adds up to an
environment that fosters community when
you look at these two side-by-side which
would you choose
[Music]
while some malls are being repurposed
others are just getting torn down this
is in part because of the recession in
2008 while more than 90% of purchases in
the United States are still made in
physical stores more and more people are
getting their goods online and we aren't
just shopping online our relationships
and connections are going digital as
well more than three and four people in
the United States has a smartphone when
social media is used to actively connect
with others it can be like a digital
third place but studies like this one
show that some digital communication can
affect your mental or even physical
health the mall occupies a unique space
in America's conscience and that's
largely because we have an innate need
for face-to-face contact and in some
areas the mall was that place but as
more malls shut down so too are other
third places and the replacements often
have little stake in the local community
but there is a better way consider the
public beaches and downtown Detroit or
the redevelopment of Bryant Park in New
York City or you could just support a
locally owned coffee shop the decline of
the mall doesn't need to be the death of
the third place it's up to us to decide
where those spaces will be
you